but we have next Michael Pearson who's
an associate professor of global
sustainability and social
entrepreneurship as well as the director
for the center for humanistic management
at Fordham University he is also
research fellow here at Harvard
University and a full member of the Club
of Rome
dr. Pearson is a scholar of humanistic
management which holds we just heard
that business and commerce ought to
protect human dignity and societal
well-being he helped found the
humanistic management Network a global
organization brings together academics
from various disciplines together with
practitioners policymakers and media
representatives to accelerate the
transition towards a life life conducive
economic system professor Pierson is
also actively exploring the role of
higher education in positive change
making in social innovation leading
Fordham University's efforts as an ash
oka Ashoka changemaker campus professor
Pierson established the social
entrepreneurship track chair for the
Ashoka global case writing competition
and social entrepreneurship and serves
on the board of five social enterprises
a native of Germany Michael Pearson has
worked and lived in Switzerland France
China Costa Rica in the United States
before beginning his academic career he
worked for an international consulting
group for several years and then started
his own private consultancy he's worked
for and with business nonprofits
embassies political campaigns and local
and national governments he's won
numerous awards for his work including
from the Academy of Management so dr.
Pearson you're one of the the architects
of humanistic management and we're
delighted to have you here today to help
us understand what humanistic management
is what does it entail what are its core
theoretical and practical implications
and again how do we distinguish it from
what comes before us in business ethic
literature and management practice great
well thank you very much bill thank you
very much Mona well thank you for being
here I and thank you for this topic and
in some ways
is great to see that we're discussing
some of these issues that for my
personal perspective this is wonderful I
think at the same time it's tragic
because we're looking at developing
trust and ethically healthy
organizations and as philosophers have
said when we talk about trust well
usually we do it when we don't have it
when there's a lack of it when there's
the absence of it similar things might
apply to ethically healthy organizations
we talk about them because there's a
lack of it so in that sense I think
that's rather tragic and I think I want
to make sure that I acknowledge the work
of my colleagues at the humanistic
management Network we've come together
about 10 years ago because we were
grappling with this question and we had
not had all the various demos own crises
yet but I think it's pretty obviously
we'll have some more and and the
question is okay why is the standard of
organizing not a different one
why does two seem to be that the most
important most powerful organizations we
have are why are they set up in a way
that's really not all that productive to
developing trust or considered ethically
healthy so that basic question drove us
to really develop an understanding
together in terms of very basic
questions how we organize first to begin
with in a very descriptive way but then
also how could we organized in a
prescriptive way and how should we
organize in a much more normative way
and I want to show you a little bit of a
video that highlights I think the the
work in some way it may be a little bit
simplistic reductionists and lacking
neurons I'll invite that as a basis for
conversation later so I can add some of
it but I want to highlight what we've
been thinking why we're doing this so if
I can get this to go it's three minutes
long and basically it highlights the the
dilemma that I think we're facing
currently
we are living in tumultuously
an array of global crises challenging
the way we think and do business
Einstein famously stated we can't solve
problems by using the same kind of
thinking we used when we created them
still the practitioners of mainstream
business as well as their teachers seem
to lack such an alternative way of
thinking as William Allen the former
Chancellor of the Delaware Court of
Chancery notes one of the marks of a
truly dominant intellectual paradigm is
the difficulty people have in even
imagining an alternative view at the
humanistic management Network our work
on conceptualizing this much-needed
alternative humanistic paradigm starts
by laying out the dominus narrative of
the current economist expand on we argue
that our understanding of who we are as
people
fundamentally influences the way we
organize individually in groups in
organizations and in society
we present these two narratives in
business The Economist ik paradigm the
dominant model represented by Homo
economicus
that accurately represents about one
percent of the population and the
alternative model the humanistic
paradigm represented by the 99 percent
of the population
while more scientific evidence supports
the latter perspective on human beings
economics and management have
pneumatically adopted an understanding
based on assumptions supporting the
former the understanding of human beings
as uncaring and narrowly self-interested
has influenced the way business
structures are set up limited liability
and focus on profit maximization the
humanistic perspective allows us to
understand the importance of care the
notion of human dignity and the
evolutionary reasons why humans only
survived when organizing for the
good this more scientifically supported
perspective allows us to envision
organizations as caring communities that
converge to produce wider benefits the
humanistic management network has
chronicled numerous organizations that
follow the humanistic paradigm the fact
that many organizations are run
successfully and oftentimes better
proves that alternatives to the current
economists ik understanding of
organizing exist reality proves
possibility and can thus inform theory
we argue that a focus on human dignity
understood as that which escapes all
price mechanism and is valued
intrinsically can improve theoretical
accuracy of current paradigms if we set
out to organize in ways that include the
common good we may be able to understand
how business can contribute better to
solving current global problems to learn
more visit WWE Network org
okay thank you very much for the
opportunity for that what plug but I
thought this was in some way some basic
information about what I think we are in
right now it's not that we lack facts
evidence or even theories I think it's
bigger than this we're lacking a
different mindset or the level of
mindfulness to engage in alternative
options to think about how we organize
and I think if we just had more and I'm
not saying the humanistic perspective is
the only one or should be the only one
but it is what we're trying to do is to
provide another one so that we can
explore in different ways how we can
organize better and how can we possibly
develop more trust and how can we
develop healthy ethical organisations in
our work just to sort of categorize some
of these potential alternative
perspectives in a very parsimonious way
and that's why I apologize but I think
we can get into some of the conversation
and about the points that you raised
later I think that if we want to think
about theory and thinking about how we
organize the current way to do so
understand force for good reasons that
we need simplicity and our understanding
and economists ik thinking or let's say
the Homo economicus fits that bill it's
a very good model for certain certain
things but unfortunately it creates a
narrative that goes beyond its original
purpose and that narrative has power and
has performativity it is influential and
we have all the studies about how
students exposed to the Homo economicus
model perform ethically much poorer even
just in let's say a course or in the
duration of a course so there is an
effect one that we don't really like if
we're talking about these issues today
so I think we need to complement our
understanding of how
who we are as human beings as one
narrative that we call humanistic which
includes dignity right and Kant famously
said everything that doesn't have a
price has dignity it's something that we
don't trade it therefore logically does
not fit in a market mechanism and if we
can't really talk about it that way
through pricing mechanisms or even just
the quantitative evaluation or in
research through simple quantification
as well and what we're thinking behind
that I think even bigger than that is
that we need to engage in shifts of
mindset and just exploring what these
alternatives could be in terms of our
very simple parsimonious thinking to
even get a step forward right we all
know Occam's razor when something is
very simple even if it's wrong you want
to have it as long as you sort of don't
have a more accurate purse ammonius
theory
so dignity is a complex concept it
increases complexity of a theory but I
think it increases accuracy as well so
what we're trying to do is the input
notion here in terms of our theory of
who we are or reorganized for needs to
include this notion of dignity there are
certain ways that we can theorize that
we can practice that we can teach that
we can create policy that neglects
dignity and that focuses on wealth
creation as the ultimate objective okay
we call that economists there are ways
as presented the to respect and protect
dignity and still focus on wealth
creation which is bounded economists and
then there are a lot of conversations
about how we can promote dignity to
increase wealth and I think that is the
typical CSR conversation in many ways
how do we engage in socially responsive
activity or maybe in protecting dignity
to really just basically increase our
bottom line possibly
I think that's fatal in many ways if we
stick to that kind of understanding and
that's why I think we need to really
rethink the objective function and the
purpose and going back to Aristotle
economy I was always considered to
contribute not to wealth
but to well-being to happiness right so
we oughta start already knew there are
different types of organizing he called
the other one chromaticity the one that
we described here economists but the
humanistic perspective the well-being
creation could be an alternative view so
the objective function shifts then we
have different models and the one that
is I think that Nina was referring to
that provides for this dangerous kind of
organizing where well possibly we are
going for the common good
but we're neglecting dignity which
includes all totalitarianism which
includes paternalistic structures which
is dangerous and we need to be very
clear that this is a trap that could be
coming under the humanistic label and I
think we need to be very clear that this
dignity is the distinction the
protection of dignity doesn't allow for
totalitarianism or even paternalism and
we call it bounded humanism and then the
ultimate form we would say is promoting
dignity and well-being creation which is
a humanistic form and we think that you
can do that if you can do research
around these things if you can
reformulate your theory you can teach
differently you can practice differently
and it's already done in many different
ways and you can formulate policy and
that's already happening but I think we
need to go back if we have the question
that how can we develop trust and
ethically healthy organizations I think
we need to increase our level of
mindfulness and shift also mindsets
about it so that's I think where I leave
it for now
you